I jumped out of the airplane and then my
first shoot didn't open they cut it's
tandem so somebody's on your back they
cut that line
we started Free Falling Towards Earth
and that's when you get the you know
eight by ten glossies of your whole life
flashing before your eyes and then the
second one was Tangled as well and I saw
my friend sort of popping off with their
you know their parachutes and I'm still
plummeting towards planet Earth that was
Tangled for about a good I don't know 20
30 seconds and then he untangled it and
then he told me oh you're probably gonna
break your legs now because this we're
going too fast so it was one of the
worst experiences of my life and I'll
never do it again